RICH: Hey there.
Welcome to this week's Android
Developer office hours.
There was a glitch in the matrix
and it went ping twice.
I'm joined here today by--
MATT: Matt Gaunt.
NICK: Nick Butcher.
RICH: And I'm Richard Hyndman.
We're based in the London
office of Google.
And we're here to take your
Android development questions,
should you have any.
So please join us in the Hangout
today, come along and
ask any Android relevant
questions you may have.
You can ask them in the
moderator, you can find that
at developers.google.com/live,
or you can ask them on the
comment thread to this
particular Hangout.
Maybe we'll just hang around for
a second, see if someone
joins us in the Hangout.
[INAUDIBLE]
NICK: It's always more fun
if you have some live
participants.
Other than that it's--
MATT: It's the first time I
think I've ever done a Hangout
with you guys where it's just
been silent from the start.
Too silent.
NICK: Have we answered all
the Android development
questions there are?
MATT: Never in life.
They're exhausted.
RICH: Well let me see.
Unfortunately clock--
Excellent.
I'm going to open up the thread
for this Hangout and
see if there's anyone
asking to join.
Couple of views on YouTube.
Maybe we should check the
YouTube comments.
MATT: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: That's really getting to
the bottom of the barrel when
we need to look for YouTube
comments for Android
development questions.
NICK: That's a good point.
We should say if you want to
ask questions and you don't
want to jump into the Hangout,
you're too shy, then feel free
to, as Rich says, either post on
the G+ thread where Android
developers says it's Hanging
out, you can post there, or
you can post comments on the
YouTube, or you can submit
them to the moderator, which
you can find if you go to
developers.google.com/live we
should be the top show on
there saying live now.
And you can post a comment
right there.
RICH: I may have mentioned
that already.
MATT: It's fine, [INAUDIBLE].
Now we are joined by Alex.
RICH: Oh, we've got two people
in there, we've got Alex and--
MATT: Jerry McDowell.
RICH: Oh, we got Pete too.
MATT: Oh, and Dave.
Oh, now we're taking off.
RICH: People coming
into the right--
NICK: Welcome, [? how you ?]
doing.
RICH: Rampant about
leadership.
NICK: Do any of the people
who've just joined want to say
hello, introduce themselves,
and ask a question?
ALEX: OK, I'm Alex.
I did a few weeks ago did a
ticketing system on H2 Dev.
I met Richard.
RICH: Yeah, hey Alex.
NICK: Oh cool.
RICH: Did you get it working
on the Nexus 4?
ALEX: I haven't got
any Nexus 4.
RICH: No, I know--
ALEX: [INAUDIBLE] of an
era until I get one.
MATT: How's it going?
RICH: Thanks for joining
us today.
ALEX: Well I have actually
a question on H2 Dev.
So [INAUDIBLE]
around 30 devices linked into
one Google Play account.
And we have sporadic sign-outs
on some of the devices.
Is there a limit on the number
of active devices per account?
RICH: Almost certainly.
Here comes Giuseppe
with his echo on.
You can hear straight out
of his microphone--
straight out of his speakers
back into his microphone.
Yes, there is almost
certainly a limit.
I've never come across
it myself.
But if you're trying to share
one set of credentials with a
large number of devices, I can
imagine there would be some
protection to stop that kind of
behavior, especially when
you're looking at paid
applications.
ALEX: Yeah.
I guess that for next
[INAUDIBLE]
I'll need to find something
else, probably.
RICH: One of the things that
works quite well is if you
have your own Google
Apps domain.
You can create one for free
anyway, and you get 50 free
email accounts with that.
I've seen people use that to
set up devices before.
Because we're a bit more lenient
on Google Apps domain
because you're administering
the email accounts, not us.
Whereas if you're using at
gmail.com addresses, it's us,
it's Google that's administering
those accounts
so there's stricter guidelines
on them.
ALEX: It was actually on an App
domain that the devices
were linked, and not
on a Gmail account.
RICH: OK.
Yeah, it's still
going to apply.
That same limitation
would apply.
But you could more easily create
a large number of email
addresses inside your own
domain, potentially, than you
would be able to
in our domain.
ALEX: So we'll use different
email accounts
for X number of devices.
RICH: I don't know if the real
names policy applies to people
inside their own domains.
I imagine it don't know--
I guess it doesn't.
Because you're not signing
up under conditions.
It's your own administrators.
MATT: Yeah, I wouldn't
have thought so--
Why would--
Yeah, Real Names wouldn't
affect it, would it?
RICH: I don't know.
MATT: I don't think so.
RICH: The account administrator
would have to.
Anyway, I've certainly used that
approach before to try
and get round some of
these is issues.
ALEX: Thanks.
RICH: Not a problem at all.
Hey, Giuseppe, good
to see you again.
How you doing?
GIUSEPPE: Hey.
Good to see you as well again.
How are you?
[INAUDIBLE]?
RICH: Yeah, yeah, we're all
doing fine, thank you.
Back from our travels in
Antwerp and Amsterdam.
GIUSEPPE: I know.
I watched all the
[? pictures. ?]
NICK: It feels like it
was since we've sat
in this room, right?
We've been on location
for a while?
Having crazy--
GIUSEPPE: I saw have very,
very short woman.
There was not many,
many girls, right?
[INAUDIBLE].
I thought you saw
a short woman.
I was like, what?
MATT: Yeah, where you going--
RICH: I saw a short
woman, yeah--
No, you're right. there weren't
many girls at DroidCon
Holland, I guess or--
NICK: Holland was a better
mix than some.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah.
But the question is--
RICH: That's true.
GIUSEPPE: The question is, there
was no girl because they
don't they care about Android,
or they don't they care about
the guys that was there?
Big question.
RICH: We need to
ask that, yeah.
NICK: I wish I knew
the answer.
RICH: Tim Bray, he always does
in his Devoxx keynote each
year, he just shouts at the
audience to employ more in
tech, and making it more
friendly for women in tech.
he just has a complete rant .
GIUSEPPE: I just waited
one week.
Any chance to understand how
we can receive these
[INAUDIBLE]
directly into application?
NICK: I didn't hear that.
MATT: I didn't.
RICH: How to proceed with what
directly into application?
Yes,
GIUSEPPE: I would like to
receive a Bluetooth file
directly into application.
This was last question
of last week.
RICH: He's got a good
point, it was.
But, I said last week you should
add into the moderator
for this week so we review it.
But I don't see it there,
so it wasn't there.
GIUSEPPE: I can put right
now if you want, or--
RICH: I still don't
know how to do it.
GIUSEPPE: [LAUGHING]
RICH: It doesn't change
the fact that I don't
know how to do it.
GIUSEPPE: I looked very well
through development papers and
I didn't find anything useful,
so I think that--
or there is no solution to get
the Bluetooth directly into
the app, or we must find
something [INAUDIBLE]
or group [? mirror. ?]
I used some [? root ?] code
from Motorola open source.
They had some Bluetooth
[? adaptive ?].
[INAUDIBLE].
But starting with 4.1,
I cannot anymore open
[INAUDIBLE]
Bluetooth device.
So the Bluetooth
[? adaptive ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
is just a [INAUDIBLE]
cannot get it anymore
starting with 4.1.
MATT: So what was the problem
with opening up a sub-kit and
getting the information
through that?
Is that a problem?
RICH: I guess he wants to use
Bluetooth file transfer
protocol so any other
application on any device can
send it without having
to be his
application on another device.
MATT: Yeah.
RICH: I know-- yeah,
[INAUDIBLE].
MATT: Yeah.
That's my [? inexperience-- ?]
RICH: I don't know if the
foreground activity can
override Bluetooth file
handling or not.
And I didn't check out because
it wasn't on the moderator and
I totally forgot.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
I will put in the moderator
for next one?
RICH: All I'm going to do is
look in the same places that
your developers would
look in, right?
I'm just going straight to the
Android developer documents
and Stack Overflow then repeat
which I find to you.
It may be quicker to search
those sources yourself.
GIUSEPPE: You know very well how
Stack Overflow will work.
If there is no answer your
question is left alone.
No one--
anyone suggests.
RICH: You know, there's quite
a few Android engineers that
answer questions directly on
Stack Overflow though.
And members of our
team as well.
GIUSEPPE: So you
are [INAUDIBLE]
the question, then.
RICH: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
GIUSEPPE: I will do that.
Thank you.
RICH: Put it on Stack Overflow
in case the answer is there
already, of course.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
Thanks.
NICK: It does that
for you, right?
When you're trying to place
the question it
says, did you mean?
RICH: I don't know--
NICK: Has someone else already
asked that question?
GIUSEPPE: No, someone, somebody
else saying to you,
paste your code here.
But what code?
[INAUDIBLE] the writing.
RICH: Excellent.
Yeah, sorry, we totally
forgot about that.
Does anybody else from the
Hangout have any questions
before we jump into the first
one from the moderator today?
JUSTIN: Oh, I have a question.
RICH: Hi there.
MATT: Justin, is it?
RICH: Who said that?
Did he say that?
MATT: Yeah, Justin.
RICH: Go ahead.
Shoot.
JUSTIN: So my question is
actually Bluetooth related and
it is, the Google music gap is
somehow getting information
over like ABCRP 1.3, I think it
is and so users are able to
see artists and albums
on a car stereo.
That's excellent.
And so, I'd like to be able to
do the same thing, and one or
two other apps are also doing
it, but I can't find any
documentation, and
also can't find
anything on Stack Overflow.
It's like a hidden
secret right now.
NICK: Source code?
RICH: I was going to say, just
look at the source code for
the music app?
JUSTIN: You can get source
code to Google music?
RICH: It should under
the packages of
the open source project.
JUSTIN: I think you can get the
source code for the old
music app but not like Google
music that streams music.
RICH: Fair enough.
No, It's possible.
NICK: Yeah, I think that's
right, actually.
The old one's in--
RICH: OSP's got the old one?
NICK: [INAUDIBLE] music is the
old version, before it went
Google Music, [? now it's ?]
just Music.
RICH: Yeah, so it's possible
that those guys aren't using--
[? [LOUD AIRPLANE NOISE] ?]
Ah, mute.
It's possible that those guys
aren't using the high level
Bluetooth APIs.
They may well be doing it using
the NDK or something,
opening Bluetooth connections
and sending the data across.
I don't know.
I haven't seen any high level
Bluetooth APIs for doing
anything like that.
JUSTIN: OK.
So I should just post
to Stack Overflow?
RICH: Yeah, if no-one has
already written an
implementation which can do what
you want, it may be quite
tricky to write that.
MATT: I guess if you also get
then someone who might have
more experience at different
level Bluetooth or various
things on other sides of it
might be able to guide you and
might look for the answer.
It may not be a case you get the
answer, but people might
be able to guide you, just
[? germinate, ?] start
thinking about it, looking about
it, other examples that
may be relevant.
RICH: Over the last three weeks,
we've had quite a lot
of Bluetooth questions
coming up now.
So--
NICK: Didn't you promise
to set up a
Bluetooth focused Hangout?
RICH: I think promise is
a little bit strong.
MATT: Submitted?
RICH: Submitted, suggested?
Suggested that one
of us do it?
MATT: Threw it out there.
RICH: On our--
NICK: List of demands.
RICH: It does seem to be--
something that we're either
lacking documentation on or
something that we should
have a show
specifically dedicated to.
We'll keep in a stronger
suggestion of getting that put
together in the near future.
I know that we're traveling
again quite a lot until
Christmas so it's going to be
tricky, but it's going to have
to go to the top of the list
of things to focus on.
Is either more Bluetooth
documentation or just more
information about
it generally.
NICK: OK.
Well looking in the comment
thread here on the G+ post,
there's a couple questions
coming in.
I guess we didn't really cover
off our normal disclaimer at
the top of the show.
RICH: Oh, [? stop me-- ?]
MATT: Is somebody asking
for a road map?
NICK: So, yeah, again this is
really focused on Android
development and chatting about
how to develop Android apps.
And we're not going to be able
to answer questions such as
when is Google Now coming
to Argentina?
Unfortunately we're not going to
be able to make those kind
of pronouncements.
And someone else's asking when
he's going to get an update,
to his Galaxy Nexus, again, I
don't know, is the answer.
I know it's rolling
out slowly.
Just keep on mashing that Check
For Updates button and
see what happens.
There is one question which is,
Thomas asks if we're going
to bring back a pragmatic
way to switch
flight mode on and off.
It's an interesting question,
because this is one of the
changes I think we covered
briefly last week, in fact.
Where with the changes to
[INAUDIBLE] the introducing
multi users, we moved some of
the settings into a global
settings, [INAUDIBLE]
device rather than a user
specific setting.
One of which was the setting
for flight mode.
So I'm going to take a bit of
issue with the question where
it says will we bring back a
pragmatic API for turning off
flight mode.
I would actually argue that
there never was a pragmatic
API, explicit API, for turning
on and off flight mode.
People worked out how to poke a
value into a settings table
and do something else for it to
take effect, but that was
never actually a documented
API, I'd say.
People kind of working out
how to do it isn't
really the same thing.
I'd say when we have an actual
API, like a connectivity
manager dot whatever, that's a
commitment for us to support
and say this is how you
do such a thing.
so I think that's why we kind of
felt able to move where it
was and perhaps some
applications may no longer be
able to turn off flight mode,
that's just the way it is.
So that's the long answer saying
that yeah, we're not
going to bring it back
because it never
really kind of existed.
But the second part of this
question asks is there a way
to ask for such improvements?
And the answer is yes.
So if you go to b.android.com,
which is where you have
details on how to file bugs on
the Android platform, you can
file a bug with a type
feature request.
And log a feature request.
It may sound like you're
shouting into a black hole,
but we do actually
read every single
bug and feature request.
We may not have time to respond
to all of them and
comments and get into
discussions, but we do
certainly read them all.
Or the Android core, Android
[INAUDIBLE] team and product
managers read them
all and factor
them into next releases.
So, yeah, there is definitely
log your feature request there
or search if there's an existing
one and get people to
star it to show how much
people want it.
RICH: Absolutely.
And for applications that were
setting flight mode,
definitely they should be
sending users now directly to
the setting screen for that.
The network settings screen.
I know that quite a lot of the
home screen widgets have
already done that update.
So pressing that widget now
just goes there instead.
The issue is of course for those
applications that set it
automatically, Yeah.
It's a bit tough for them.
There won't be a way
of doing that.
Yes, Giuseppe, you can ask
questions about the Developer
Play console.
GIUSEPPE: So [INAUDIBLE]
probably already famous, but I
would like to hear from you
the [INAUDIBLE]
what, and especially I want--
NICK: Giuseppe, we're having
some trouble hearing you.
Can you perhaps move your
microphone a bit closer to
your mouth?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah.
Now, better?
NICK: Yeah--ish.
GIUSEPPE: Let me see.
OK.
I'm want [INAUDIBLE]
microphone--
RICH: The microphone's on
your headset, right?
GIUSEPPE: You like now?
RICH: Oh, hello.
GIUSEPPE: OK, very good.
Sorry.
I was using another
microphone.
Anyway, I would like to know
about the search and the
position criteria.
Let me make an example.
I have an application that
the name is Giuseppe.
OK, Giuseppe.
If I search in the toolbar, I
search Giuseppe, I find the
first page with other
applications that have some
Giuseppe word inside of the
description and in the second
page I find my application that
have Giuseppe as name.
NICK: Uh-huh.
Correct
GIUSEPPE: So the criteria of
their search I think is all
wrong or something's
not working well.
And second the position.
How is it possible that in the
same category, there are from
the first to the 10 position,
there are applications that
have very low downloads, very
low review range, but they are
in the first 10 position,
and my application that
has every day good--
RICH: Yeah, yeah, we--
GIUSEPPE: Rating.
Everyday, yeah what is it?
And just to finish, what this
is review now with,
a Google user say?
A Google user.
We don't see any more the
name of the user.
Last week we were able to find
the name and to try to
understand what is the problem
and to reply to the user.
But now we really lost the
contact with the user.
So we are going to not get any
more any chance to reply to
these review?
RICH: You know, you will.
Calm down.
It's OK.
It's getting better,
not worse.
So the first one, obviously we
don't really comment on search
algorithms, things like that.
But the search algorithms
are based on a
huge number of criteria.
They are there to produce,
en masse, the best
results for the users.
It may not be the best results
for when you're searching for
your own personal application,
it's an iterated algorithm to
provide good results for
users in search.
NICK: And just like our Google
search, we don't go into the
exact details of which factors
contribute to it.
I mean that's kind of our secret
sauce, and also it'd
probably be wrong, because it's
changing every single
day, and we're always tweaking
these algorithms trying to
produce the best possible
search results.
So we're not going to be
able to go into that.
RICH: You'll find things in
there related to rate of
change as well as just
fixed values.
the same when we're
ranking things.
The rate of change of things
inside the application.
and of the ratings, and the
number of installs, number of
uninstalls, all those sort of
things can affect it and the
rate of change of those things
can affect it as well.
GIUSEPPE: Hm.
RICH: As we say those things,
we're trying to search through
almost 3/4 of a million
applications and surface the
right one for your search term,
and the search team are
constantly iterating
that algorithm.
like the web search as well,
some people it benefits, some
people it doesn't, and they try
and make a good balance.
The same goes for the category
rankings as well.
NICK: I think it's doing
the right job.
Just because it's the exact
match for the title doesn't
mean it's the best match
for the search term.
RICH: I could very easily spam
the search results just by
putting exact matches for--
for car in there and hopefully
my app would go to the top.
But actually, it should be at
the very, very bottom at
700,000 until it has some
traffic and some
reviews and so on.
I know it's not ideal
for some people.
It works very well for
a lot of people.
GIUSEPPE: Which of you know the
name of the application?
I will not say here because
it's not correct.
RICH: Yeah, of course.
GIUSEPPE: But if you try to
make the research on the
Google Play market, you will
understand what I mean.
You will see many, many, many
applications that have nothing
to do with this name, and my
application is just in the
second and this for me
is very strange.
It's like I'm looking for
someone that is named Richard,
Google and he'd return
to me Thomas.
That's it.
RICH: I see it down there.
The issue with that is almost
the second word of the
application name.
NICK: Yeah, it's a very--
RICH: It's too generic--
NICK: Very, very common word.
RICH: It's matching that
second word, the word--
GIUSEPPE: No, it's pretty
common words, but both
together, only mine.
The two words together,
just mine.
RICH: If I put quotes around
the two words of the
application name--
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, but quotes is
for professional searcher--
RICH: No but the rest of it--
GIUSEPPE: Not for
people people.
RICH: I mean, search is done
by individual words.
And you can't hope to come in
the top for the word "pro",
unless you're--
NICK: I'd consider changing
the name.
MATT: Yeah, I've had this in
one of my apps where I had
loads of people who had
kind of phony apps.
So eventually the Play team
kind of adjusted things.
And I just made sure that all I
did was just make sure I had
a good description, had
a good title, and
everything made sense.
Beyond that I just left it.
And eventually my app just
kind of filtered its
way up to the top.
But I did notice that the Play
team, they were adjusting it,
and changing the algorithm--
I don't think there's anything
you can do to force it, just
do what is right and just
stick with that.
And like you say, pro is
kind of a generic term.
It is a bit bad.
RICH: Yeah, obviously we're
not going to be able to
influence that algorithm.
We can let the team
know, but--
and then regarding
the reviews, yes?
Previously, anyone could
type any name they
wanted into that box.
And they were unverified.
So I could go in and put
Giuseppe [? Bocelli ?]
in, as the reviewer and say
whatever I wanted about your
application.
So now we've put all those just
down to a Google user,
and all reviews from now on
are verified against the
Google+ account.
So from now on, you'll be able
to see exactly who reviewed it
and it'll be verified against
that Google account.
Their real identity that
they're logged in with.
NICK: It should be better for
conversations, going back to
what he says.
RICH: So you'll see--
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: The latest reviews--
MATT: I missed that--
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? verificate ?] what
will happen?
We will see the name?
RICH: Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
GIUSEPPE: Or we will see--
NICK: You can already
see it, actually.
If you go to some popular apps
and sort the reviews by newest
first, say since this
change happened,
you'll see this result.
So you'll see the real people
and their G+ profile pictures
pulled in even, so yeah, it's
forming a real conversation
with a real person.
RICH: So in the review section,
you have to go and
see "See All", and then it
brings up a page of all the
reviews, and then there's a
filter the top where you can
say newest first, and on there
you'll see them starting to
come in with real
people's names,
verified accounts on them.
Verified identities.
Best to go for an application
that's getting thousands of
reviews everyday and you'll see
them all with real names
and photographs next
to them as well.
The G+ profile photo will appear
next to it as well.
GIUSEPPE: Oh, yes.
That's very good now.
RICH: It was just a--
NICK: So worry not.
It's getting better.
RICH: It's getting better but
we have to do that before--
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, it's getting
better, yeah.
Do you think that in the future
there would be any
chance to reply [INAUDIBLE]
review?
RICH: Yeah, I'd hope so.
it is in trial at the moment.
Still in this trial phase.
Trying to figure out how people
best use that feature
and make sure it's not
used for the wrong--
NICK: What I'm excited about
is when you remove the
anonymity of just being able to
put any name then there's
less useless comments
or hateful stuff.
people are a bit more considered
in their comments,
I feel, when it's your
name and photo.
So hopefully it increases
the quality of
the discourse.
GIUSEPPE: Correct.
Yes.
RICH: And following through,
hopefully the quality of the
applications because you can
really trust those reviews.
Welcome to everybody else that
has just joined us in the
Hangout, including Yossi.
Good to see you back
on again there.
What have you got in your lower
third today, Yossi?
Say something so I can see it.
NICK: I think you're
muted right now.
YOSSI: Hi guys.
RICH: There we go.
Yossi.
OK.
Sometimes you can't find
your stuff down there.
NICK: Proud father.
RICH: Yeah.
It's on my--
YOSSI: Still proud father today
and for the rest of my
life, also.
RICH: OK.
Does anyone in the Hangout--
anyone else in the Hangout
have a question, before--
PATRICK: Yeah, guys,
I've got one.
This is Patrick.
I have a question on the Android
emulator on Mac.
Ever since updating the SDK,
if you close the Android
emulator on a secondary monitor,
you can't restart it.
It'll crash every time.
And you have to edit the
emuatoruser.ini to change the
window position so it's back
on the primary monitor.
RICH: Thank you very much.
PATRICK: It's really kind of
painful for my workflow
because I have three screens.
And I typically have
the emulator
off the primary monitor--
RICH: The good news about
this is the Tools
team is super reactive.
And if you go to
tools.android.com, you can
file a bug there and they will
read it the same day.
NICK: Or probably place it
to ADT-Dev, actually.
Quickest way.
RICH: OK.
PATRICK: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK: Yeah, if you search for
the Google Group called ADT
dash Dev, that's Android
Developer Tools Dev,
PATRICK: OK.
NICK: Post it in there, and
I'm sure they'll see it.
RICH: Post any information you
have on there, and they'll get
it sorted out as soon
as possible.
I do run a similar
system here.
I haven't tested that use case
so I'll test it out myself
after the Hangout as well.
PATRICK: OK.
Thanks.
I'll give that a try.
RICH: Thanks very
much, though.
Really good to hear
that feedback.
Anything happening in
the comments thread?
NICK: There's one question here
in the comments thread
from Alex, who asks if there
are any Miracast dongles
available yet.
Not that I know of.
[LOUD TYPING]
Miracast is very early days.
It's only been ratified as a
standard very, very recently
we're kind of getting--
everyone's super excited.
I'm really excited to try it.
I haven't even tried out one
of these dongles yet.
RICH: Yeah, there was one on
Amazon in the states- there
was one on Amazon US that said
that it supports both the
Intel and Miracast standard.
But no one here is--
I haven't seen it yet.
MATT: There's a couple of
questions after that one
that's just come in.
RICH: Uh-huh.
MATT: So Dmitri asks--
so basically, he's trying
to access the list
of files on an ADB.
In the sense that he's using
the method environment.get
external storage directly,
and then on that
calling list files.
And he's saying on an ADB that
will return no, whereas on a
device it returns
as documented.
And he's doing a check to see
whether the media is actually
mounted as well.
NICK: Theres no files on
the SD card on the ADB?
MATT: Yeah, that's what I'm
wondering, either it's not
actually mounted, or it
could just be empty.
Double check.
NICK: So one way would be to,
in DDMS you can actually
explore the SD card, right?
Of the emulator.
[? What of ?] checking to see
if there are actually files,
or just create a file and
see what it lists?
MATT: All context.
And then there's another
one from Tim Rose.
Question about HTTP client
versus HTTP URL connection.
Note, blog entry from 2011
states HTTP URL connection
should be preferred
above Android 2.3.
Just had a discussion in
#android-dev on Freenode
that's about that.
HTTP URL connections seems
from Android 4.0 to have
several bugs too.
what's the current
recommendation about those two?
HTTP client's offers
some features HTTP
URL connection doesn't.
HTTP custom HTTP methods are
acceptable to use or should it
be avoided?
So I guess it's which one?
NICK: The general advice is from
2.3 onwards, so that's
from Gingerbread onwards, to
use URL connection because
that's the one which is
receiving active developments
and productization.
You're very echoey.
You might have to--
KENTON: Done.
NICK: You've got headphones.
Cheers.
OK.
So the current advice
is-- that's
still the correct advice.
All the work is going on in URL
connections so things like
response caches and so on
are getting added to URL
connection, not actively worked
on in HTTP client.
But then again, HTTP client is
a very, very rich and well
tested library from Apache.
So it does offer a plethora of
options which I guess haven't
quite made it into URL
connection yet.
So if there's something super
specific that URL connection
doesn't offer yet, I consider
it completely valid to use
HTTP client.
I would say for, above
Gingerbread, use URL
connection where possible unless
you can't help-- it's
[INAUDIBLE] case that
isn't covered yet.
MATT: Good advice.
I completely agree, I think.
I've probably used both of them,
and it's just completely
dependent on what
I needed to do.
RICH: David Chandler is our web
and web view expert from
the Android developer
relations team.
So if you look for David
Chandler on Google+, he may be
able to provide more insights
into any specifics as well.
NICK: And he also created a kind
of HTTP library, didn't
he, which kind of sits above the
two and we'll do the right
thing and above nine it will use
URL connection and below
use client and have an
abstraction layer on top of
the two, so take a look
for that as well.
Rich is feverishly Googling for
it to post a link of as a
reply to the question.
MATT: Anyone else on the Hangout
got any questions?
RICH: What's that?
GoogleCodeBasic-HTTP-Client that
you can find it on his
blog at TurboManage.
So it's Basic-HTTP-Client--
NICK: Paste a link of
it as a response.
RICH: Googlecode.com.
I will-- he only did this on the
6th of December-- the 6th
of December.
NICK: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: That's the 12th of July.
June.
NICK: American dates.
Where is it.
GIUSEPPE: Come on, come on.
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK: We got it.
Ninja hand.
GIUSEPPE: You got it?
I would like to see
if you got it.
I would like to see.
MATT: If he caught it
or if it smashed.
YOSSI: Can you hear me now?
RICH: Yes, hey Yossi,
sounds good.
YOSSI: I have a question.
RICH: No, go right ahead.
YOSSI: My question
is about loaders.
Since API 11, basically loaders
were added to simplify
the use and not use
[INAUDIBLE]
or whatever, and use loaders
to fetch all the data.
and then the lower level will
handle all the configuration
changes for us.
But basically, if I have only
one entry point for data, say
I'll do an IM client, OK?
Not [? over. ?]
I'm saying--
OK, tell you what.
Another thing.
I'll do a phone dialer
app, OK?
But all the contacts
are on the server.
So basically on the first login,
I'll fetch all the data
once and then I'll just store
that on the device or in
database or in memory and
basically do all the
manipulations on it.
So how loaders can help me or
save me time because I still
need to use adapters for the
list view or basically switch
all the data from cursor
adapters to the list view and
loaders is just another way
to fetch the data, right?
Or is it more than
meets the eye?
NICK: No, that's
exactly right.
It's an alternative to just
doing your own query on the
content resolver.
But it's a bit smarter.
YOSSI: So basically I don't
have an obligation to use
loaders if I can handle all the
configuration changes myself?
NICK: Yeah, it's not [INAUDIBLE]
to be an
obligation.
It's just convenience.
It's there to help make
it easier for you.
YOSSI: Yeah, but I mean in
performance wise, is it better
than using our own check for
configuration changes?
Because basically all I do is
fetch the data first time upon
log in to see if that contact
list has changed, and then
basically do all the
manipulations myself and
switch from our adapter to
another list viewer and so on,
so all the data is always
on the list view--
or an adapter.
So--
NICK: You are seeing, it's
going to be a better
performance.
Chances are [INAUDIBLE]
no.
Because the joy of loaders is it
takes care of a lot of work
for you, right?
So it's just like the content
observer for you, for example.
So for me that's one of the
joys, that you can decouple--
say you're querying
a rest service.
You can just fire off to an
intent service, and have the
intent service retrieve
information and put it into
the content provider.
and you don't have to worry
about then trying to touch the
UI because the loader's
implemented the content
observer for you.
It'll just see the change on the
content URI and re-query
and update your UI for you.
So you don't have to then get
into the messy logic of result
receivers and so on trying to
ping back from your intent
service back to your activity.
And yes, the joy of it is it
kind of handles a lot of that
for you and like you say handles
configuration changes
gracefully for you as well.
so if you don't need any of
that, then don't use it.
YOSSI: I mean most likely every
app that uses fetching
from the internet and showing
list views, and so on, needs
it on different levels.
Because I can do all
the configuration
changes handling myself.
And basically if I use an array
adaptor, or a cursor
adapter to hold the data--
as a persistent data, as long
as the application is on the
foreground then I don't see
why loaders is better.
That's what I mean.
That's what I wanted to
verify with you guys.
RICH: Yeah, I concur.
YOSSI: OK.
Thanks.
NICK: I guess that one argument
might be though, that
if it changes in the future that
you might want to watch
which content changes or things
like that, then you're
then going to have to change
all your code and write all
that stuff for you, whereas
loaders are pretty easy to
implement if you just do it from
the start then if your
requirements change on you then
you have that flexibility
to react to it.
But I guess you know your
requirements better.
YOSSI: Thanks, guys.
RICH: Hey, Kenton, How you
getting on, there?
How are your single
[INAUDIBLE]--
KENTON: Wow.
There's something wrong with
this, isn't there?
I'm sorry.
Can you hear me OK, or has it
just completely screwed
everyone up.
RICH: Seems good enough.
Seems OK.
KENTON: Yeah, the thing
yesterday, I was about to
reach out about it, is all.
You wanted to know if it's the
same problem you've reported
to them already.
RICH: Oh, interesting.
OK.
KENTON: I've got to
the bottom of it.
It's basically single shot used
to give you about four or
five shots.
And now it gives you a single
shot which is probably what it
should have done in the
first place but--
it totally messed up what I
was doing with it, so--
NICK: [INAUDIBLE] single
shot [INAUDIBLE]?
KENTON: Yeah, exactly.
Because it used to return about
four progressively more
detailed versions.
So I'd just wait until I didn't
get one for 10 seconds
and then use that,
but I ignored
the first one, because--
[LAUGHING]
And now you only to
get the first one.
I don't think the first one
actually had the payload in
it, that's all.
NICK: Now all the app's
relying on [INAUDIBLE]
location, right?
KENTON: What, like Groupon.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
That's all right, I've updated
it and it's been pushed out.
Hopefully people will
see it change.
RICH: OK.
do we have any other questions
from the Hangout?
If not, we'll head into
the moderator--
ATAMA: I have a question.
RICH: Hi there.
MATT: Go for it.
ATAMA: Hello, can you hear me?
RICH: Yeah, we can hear
you fine, Atama.
ATAMA: OK.
This is my first time
on the Hangout,
and I'm pretty excited.
RICH: Well done.
ATAMA: The question I have is
that I'm pretty new to Android
developments and I notice that
I had to learn Java first in
order to develop programs--
Android applications.
just a week ago, two weeks ago,
I stumbled on a scripting
layer for Android
using Python.
And I have a very good
background with Python, and I
was wondering wouldn't it be
cool if the Android developers
can also look into the area of
integrating Python into the
SDK or having a development
platform for Python for
developing apps.
That was the question I have.
RICH: We've definitely had
internal conversations about
these things before.
I guess one of the limitations
is the size of the Tools team.
We focus very much on
progressing the platform,
progressing the APIs,
progressing all that, and if
we were supporting two sets of
APIs, with two different
languages it would just slow
everything down require a lot
more testing, and we are very
much focused on the single
language at the moment.
Plus the issue of using a
scripting language on top of
Android is you're not going to
get all the benefits of the
responsive layout tools that we
have, the resources for all
of the values.
All of the things that are built
into the core platform
to be to enable you to write
applications that work
seamlessly across the device
ranges that we have.
To port that all across another
language would be a
massive undertaking, I think.
ATAMA: OK.
RICH: But certainly there
are people who--
NICK: Well, and the platform's
moving so fast as well, right?
Like six month-ish release
schedule if not--
with a few sub-releases in
between, life 4.2.1, then it's
pretty hard to keep up with
that let alone, then--
RICH: Believe me, I can totally
see the appeal of it,
and I know why a lot of people
are doing scripting layers on
Android and things like the mono
Library as well for .net
developers.
There's definitely people who
would like to code in other
languages, but certainly
from our side--
ATAMA: Because today, Python
seems to have a lot of
libraries to handle so many
tasks, and it would also be
cool to have the developers
also concentrate in that
direction as well.
RICH: I'd say the Android
community also provides a vast
array of libraries for doing
almost anything you'd want to
do on Android as well.
People seem almost entitled to
not write code on Android
these days.
They can't find a library to
do it, they're a bit like--
what, I actually write
some code for myself?
There's so many Android specific
libraries from the
community, it's one of
the most excellent
things about Android.
ATAMA: I appreciate it.
RICH: Yeah, cheers.
Thanks for coming in, though.
If you have any other questions
feel free to send
them our way.
OK, let's take one of the
moderator then because we've
still got quite a few
to get through.
NICK: We've done a couple
of them already.
In RCLF.
RICH: OK.
Which ones haven't
we done, then?
NICK: From the top.
RICH: How do you manage
view recycling?
NICK: OK, from the top then.
So someone whose name I can't
pronounce in Colombia says,
how do you manage view recycling
when you have a
different layout from each
view on the list view?
I've tried using Get Ice and
View Type and then create a
holder class for each case, but
it does not seem to work.
Can you provide a good
solution for this?
RICH: I think that's actually
not a bad solution.
You are being asked
in Get Item for a
specific view to be returned.
And you're given a view
that's now available.
If they don't match, you're just
going to have to scrap
the one that's not available
that's come back in.
Yeah, List View in the
adapter, you have--
I can't remember what the method
is called, but it's
something like Get Item
Count, or something?
Number of items?
And then we try and
recycle the view
that is the same type.
So it does try to do a lot
of these things for you.
So when you're recycling you're
getting the right view
holder to then start
going forward.
NICK: I don't understand
what he means [? by ?]
manage view recycling.
There is a limitation there.
We don't try and hold onto at
least one of each type in the
recycle bin so that there's
already a constructed--
what is it called--
view, I guess--
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK: Get back to it.
Conveyor view.
That's the word I
was thinking of.
And so we don't actually try and
call one of each type if
there's one--
RICH: I guess, if you do have
a large list of items with
many different view types in--
or a repeating set of view
types, specifically, and you
don't want to have to keep
inflating them and you're
getting handed them back in the
wrong order, there should
be a way of caching those
convert views that come back
in or somehow keeping--
NICK: Or you could simplify it
so you don't use different
item types but you just
use view stubs
within the item types.
It's all the same type, so
you're always going to get
handed something, but
you might have to
inflate part of the stub--
RICH: And then you could
manage your own
view recycling yourself.
You could keep your own array
of all the different views
that are going to be used and
use the right layouts as you
need them that are
pre-inflated.
NICK: And also I should say,
Andrew Kelly's given a pretty
good answer in the moderator
as well.
So check that out.
RICH: Yeah, Andrew Kelly,
thanks for that.
The one-man moderator machine.
you should definitely find a way
of doing it without having
to re-inflate views that have
already been inflated.
Which-- that's quite expensive
and it's going to start
freaking with your heap.
MATT: Yeah, not that.
NICK: Don't freak
with your heap.
RICH: Don't freak
wiht the heap.
NICK: Next [? my friend-- ?]
OK.
So, DDR Boxman in Austin,
Texas asks--
he says that Android 4.2 and V11
of the spot library added
the ability to nest fragments
within other fragments.
It did indeed.
But it seems [INAUDIBLE]
to your result is broken for
these child fragments.
Is this a known bug, or
is this by design?
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH: I haven't tried
all activity
result in nested fragments.
We were just talking about
this at lunchtime.
NICK: So you're trying to set
result from within a nested
fragment and you're saying
you can't see it?
I need some more information.
RICH: So, if a nested fragment
is starting an activity for
result, is it by design that you
should have to pass that
back to the parent fragment
before you start that
activity? can the fragment start
activity results, and
where does that activity
result come back into--
MATT: I mean, I know if you
start an activity for results
from a fragment, and then the
result is going to return to
the fragment, does it
get returned to--
OK.
RICH: From the fragment
activity, at least.
Yeah.
NICK: From the activity,
not the [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT: So if it's going to
activity then presumably you
could do a bit with [? root ?]
backwards, but then you'd have
to be aware of--
RICH: That's a good point.
Can you start an activity for
result from inside a fragment?
MATT: That's what I was
thinking, because I thought
you'd have to pass objectivity
[? until ?]
you've started the result.
NICK: You mean you could start
from within the fragment but
then you'd have to catch it
from in the activity.
MATT: And then pass it down.
So maybe that's it.
RICH: Yeah.
Then it will be going back to
the parent fragment activity.
MATT: You need to make sure that
you're routing it down
the right way.
NICK: So, yeah.
I guess it is a bit confusing
exactly what
you're trying to do.
Can you post a follow up comment
with a link to Stack
Overflow or somewhere where we
can see some code, a test case
where it's failing and we can
take a look at it please?
That's my request.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH: I need to turn off key
tapping noises on this
thing, don't I?
That shouldn't be too easy.
If I hold down this button
here-- keyboard setting--
NICK: Anyway, while Rich does
that, let's crack on.
RICH: Done.
NICK: So Warlock in Prague asks,
if I have five fragments
in the back stack E G A B C D E,
where E is on top, and all
of them are instances of the
same activity class, is there
an easy way to navigate straight
from E, which is on
top, directly back to C?
I'm not using fragments
or Fragment Manager or
anything like that.
So I guess when he's saying jump
backwards, he means he
wants to pop off the top
two and to go back
to the C one there.
So you can't use the activity
flags because they're all the
same activity class.
So it's interesting is to know
why you want to do that
because it sounds like you're
trying to go straight from E
to C if it's a direct
navigation, it should be a new
one on top of the stack.
If you are just trying to get
back to where you are, as in,
are you always trying to skip
D, is that the case?
Will you always skip that?
Will you never, ever want to
come back to that D fragment?
Then there is an activity flag
that you can start to say,
don't include this in the
back stack, right?
MATT: Yeah.
There are a number of ways that
you can approach this.
The right one, I guess, would
depend purely on what you're
trying to do.
But my default instinct would be
to pick the right flag, or
if worse comes to worse, if D
you're actually done with it
once you've gone past it, then
at that point finish it.
Check flags as well as try and
come back to us with a bit
more detail and perhaps
we can give you
more of a solid answer.
Have we got any more
in the moderator?
We've got a couple
coming through--
NICK: And Yossi also helpfully
says use NavUtils, as well.
So NavUtils is in the
[? class in the ?] support
library which will help you to
synthesize back stacks and so
on, that helps you set where
to navigate to up and where
back will go, right?
YOSSI: Yeah, but basically it
can also edit think the task,
stack trace, and add task
or create new tasks.
MATT: And--
muted.
Do you have one off of the
moderator, or do you want to
go to the G+?
NICK: I think that we're running
out of moderator ones.
I think we've--
RICH: Working on trying out
that nested fragment one.
I want to go and try out nested
fragments and closing
an emulator from my
second screen.
NICK: The only unasked question
is just Tahir in New
Zealand says GPS help guide?
Question mark, question
mark, question mark.
YOSSI: We can add
more a related
question to the loaders?
NICK: Yeah, sure.
YOSSI: Say you'll have a list
of 1,000 people in your
contact list.
Before and basically you have
a status for each member in
the contact list.
And if one of the users changes
the display name or
status or something, then
basically the loader will
fetch all the data again.
And that's one big [? cons ?]
versus the adapter that we can
only change the specific data
that was changed.
NICK: Right.
Exactly.
We wouldn't want to change the
whole content URI, right?
So if anything in that content
URI changes it's going to
re-query the whole thing.
YOSSI: So that's a big
performance issue.
OK.
Just to verify.
NICK: Sure.
MATT: So what was that?
It'll pull out all of
the data again?
NICK: Yeah.
It will re-query.
MATT: If it requeries,
though, won't
necessarily be pulling out.
Just be returning a different
cursor, and then if you're
doing it to an adaptor, it'll
just pull up the data for
those views, would it not?
NICK: It's easier on
the screen, yeah.
MATT: Yeah.
NICK: But yeah, it'll have to
query the whole database.
MATT: [INAUDIBLE].
RICH: How is the G+
thread going on?
MATT: Yeah, just checking
[? it now-- ?]
RICH: I'm going to
+1 it myself.
MATT: Number 3.
[INAUDIBLE].
Question about backup manager.
How does it handle
multiple devices?
If I use the same app in
different devices, does the
developer need to do anything
special to handle it?
Can be used as a sync mechanism
between different devices?
NICK: Nope.
RICH: Personally, no.
MATT: Just a rigid no.
RICH: No.
I would try and use something
like Google Drive.
We did a code up on it recently
and its available for
G+ streams.
I quite like the idea of giving
users control over
their own data anyway.
So if you're using Google Drive
to sync your data, they
can see it, they know that
it's not in your servers,
they've got hold of it.
And it will definitely work
across all devices.
NICK: There's a couple problems
with it as well,
because when you request
sync it doesn't happen
synchronously.
It goes onto a task queue.
It happens at some point
which we don't make
any guarantees about.
So it's quite hard to guarantee
that the new state
has been synced up.
And then also, when you request
restore from Backup
Manager, That was kind
of broken on a
few versions of Android.
So it's not the most
reliable thing to--
RICH: It seems quite reliable if
you're on the same device.
But across devices there
definitely seems to be issues.
NICK: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: We haven't seen much
uptake of Backup Manager.
The actual use cases--
working use cases of it, are
quite limited at the moment.
NICK: It works really, really
well for-- don't get me wrong,
I think everyone should
use Backup Manager.
It works really well for the
case of I put a new device and
I'm signing in, please restore
my app to how it should be,
you should definitely be backing
up things like shared
preferences or in any
configuration that the use has
done to your application,
definitely use Backup Manager.
But can it be used to make a
sync client between apps?
No, that's not really what it
was built for, and it doesn't
really work that way,
unfortunately.
I'm with Rich.
Giving the users control of
their own data, for syncing
the data between devices, use
something like Drive.
RICH: And that's--
we're just specifically talking
about using Backup
Manager to backup data
to the Play servers.
Because Backup Manager's
actually a whole plug-in
framework where you can choose
to backup to SD card or your
own services.
You could write a Google Drive
Backup Manager or a Dropbox
Backup Manager plugin
if you wanted.
Or do it somewhere else.
So the limitations on the Google
Play plug-in for are
that really, it's just designed
so that as people
reinstall the applications at
the Play store, the data will
then get restored with it.
Yeah, you can choose just--
Something else to say?
NICK: Cool.
RICH: What else?
I'll just put my device down.
MATT: So Eric says, I have an
image view that is rotated
using [? dot set ?] rotation.
And shows a card framed photo
by setting a background
drawable and a photo using
set image drawable.
However only the outsides, the
background, is anti-aliased.
how can I get the front
drawable, the photo, to be
drawn anti-aliased as well?
RICH: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK: I know, isn't this?
MATT: So, how would you
anti-alias the actual photo of
an image view?
Because I'm imagining the
background's going to be dealt
with by the actual
view itself.
Whereas the image is going to
be drawn on top and actually
managed by the image view.
NICK: Only the outside
is anti-aliased.
How can the drawables be
anti-aliased as well?
MATT: A little bit of me thinks
that there should be an
option to do that.
Or whether you could
wrap the--
so if it's a resource from the
system could you not--
I'm trying to think about
there's an anti-alias option
when you wrap it in
an XML drawable?
No?
RICH: Not that I know of.
No.
NICK: I'm most interested about
what the scale type
might be on it as well.
I'm guessing the drawable's much
bigger than he's actually
displaying it on screen.
In which case that's why
he's worried about the
anti-aliasing stuff because
it has been resized down.
Can you set that with
the scale type.
Can you provide your own matrix
to scale it, or can you
pre-scale the bitmap
before setting it.
So you don't have to
set a scale type.
RICH: This is what
I'm thinking.
NICK: Yes, if you've managed
to pre-scale the bitmap
itself, you probably would have
the right flags in bitmap
manager when you scale it to do
the anti-aliasing and then
just set the scale bitmap.
RICH: If you're leaving it up to
the image view to fit, then
you end up getting provided
with it--
MATT: Thinks is the
best option.
RICH: Yeah, it's just
not going to do it.
NICK: So that's something
I'd look into.
I'd certainly try scaling the
image yourself before and then
setting the pre-scaled image
on the image view.
That's all I can think
of right now.
Any [? restrictions? ?]
anyone done this
in the Hangout?
Yeah, speak up, Giuseppe.
You're pointing at yourself.
GIUSEPPE: Thank you.
I'm using the Google Cloud
messaging successfully.
And starting two weeks, I noted
that there are about 50%
of the users that they
[? choose ?]
to get the Google
ID, that fails.
They don't get the Google ID.
Is there any insure on
the server side, or--
NICK: Ooh, I haven't even
heard that before.
GIUSEPPE: Sorry?
NICK: No, I've never heard of
a failure rate anywhere near
that before.
GIUSEPPE: No issue
at the moment.
So I get about let's
say 1,000 users.
I'm getting 500 that don't
get the response
back from the service.
NICK: You're just getting no
response at all from GCM?
GIUSEPPE: Yes they failed
to respond.
Say no registered.
RICH: Did you used to use cloud
to device messaging and
then upgrade to GCM?
GIUSEPPE: Oh yes, I upgraded
to the [INAUDIBLE]
Yes.
RICH: Are you still supporting
C2DM as well as GCM?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
RICH: And you're definitely
sending the right messages to
the right clients?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, because I
think everything's right
because I get [INAUDIBLE]
the users with the
right Google ID.
So if I want something this
don't [? master ?]
it do nothing.
RICH: No, I'm just concerned
that you've still got some of
your old user base.
I'm concerned some of your old
user base still has clients
that's using the old C2DM
format. and they'll make the
requests to your servers using
C2DM, but if you go to our GCM
servers, they will never
get the notification.
You have to send that request
through the C2DM servers to
get to those if you still have
clients that are using C2DM.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, this is
[INAUDIBLE] working now.
RICH: You sure?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, sure sure.
Because with this kind of
failure rate, it feels like
there's something serious--
I just get the GCM intern
service, I get back
[INAUDIBLE]
unregistered call.
RICH: But for the older users
that are still using C2DM?
GIUSEPPE: No.
There is no users that
is using the old API.
RICH: Are you sure?
GIUSEPPE: Sure, sure,
sure, sure.
RICH: OK.
GIUSEPPE: If you want
I can share
later the code somewhere.
RICH: Yeah.
Yeah it's possible.
Because there were some people
who had that issue that
assumed after they'd upgraded
to GCM, they only had to
support GCM.
But actually, during the
migration period they
definitely still needed to
support C2DM and GCM.
GIUSEPPE: No no no.
Our application is just using
the last version, and--
RICH: You never used
[INAUDIBLE]?
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICH: OK.
In which case, there's
definitely something wrong in
the pipeline.
We don't have any open issues
that I know about with GCM and
all the messages are getting
delivered that I know about.
And 50% is a pretty
huge failure rate.
NICK: Kenton.
You're a big GCM user, right?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, you're right.
KENTON: Yeah.
And you sometimes get some
delays getting responses from
it, but they eventually
do all come through.
NICK: But it doesn't just fail
on the registration, right?
KENTON: Say that again?
NICK: It doesn't just fail
on the registration.
I do get sometimes in my log
saying GCM not registered.
But it's already registered
anyway, so I'm not paying too
much attention to it
at that point.
And I'm not getting any
further failures.
I'm not explaining that
very well, am I?
At the moment every time the app
starts it goes through the
GCM registration process.
Which, I'm not sure that
it should do that.
I need to check into that.
But half the time it'll come
back saying GCM not
registered.
But it is registered form
the last time it run.
RICH: So I checked on known
issues, and we have no open
known issues regarding
GCM at the moment.
So it sounds more like it should
be something on your
side, Giuseppe.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah.
I will double check and
as you said I will
share the code somewhere.
RICH: Yeah, if you get any debug
through from the thing
that's failing, we might be
able to help you out.
Just mail it through and we'll
see if we can help you out.
If you can't resolve it.
GIUSEPPE: Thank you very much.
RICH: You'll find us in
the usual places.
How are we doing for time?
Oh my-- what happened
to the time?
Is it 2:59?
NICK: It is indeed.
RICH: One minute till close.
Is anything--
Anyone or anything-- you know,
it might not be a person--
have anything urgent to say?
Someone's just joined us in the
last closing seconds of
the Hangout it is--
Mark?
PAUL: Hello.
It's Paul here.
RICH: Hey Paul.
PAUL: One quick question.
I was just wondering, I know
about the orientation in
landscape and portrait.
It was quite a big
thing before.
Just wondering if--
do you think everyone is still
doing that today, or do you
think people are going for more
fixed orientations these
days on apps?
RICH: Go for both.
Support landscape
and portrait.
I Get really frustrated.
PAUL: Depending on the
screen really.
RICH: If you can do it in all
cases go then doing it in all
cases would be best.
NICK: I think it's
[? deviating ?] purpose.
I think by default every app
should support both, unless
you've got a good
reason not to.
PAUL: OK.
Thank you.
MATT: Plus, it's kind of the
beauty of Android, you don't
know what the next hit device is
going to be, and if someone
decides to do a completely
different form factor, then
it's going to be really painful
if you don't support
both the landscape and they kind
of prefer it that way.
We've been talking about an old
school G1 coming back to
life as a new--
RICH: And a lot of people use
their Nexus 7s in portrait.
Because of the particular case
I have on mine, I usually use
it in landscape.
It just happens to sit
that way on my desk.
So apps that don't support
landscape get annoying.
And you're always going to have
that section of your user
base that are on the devices
with slide out keyboards and
then they also feel excluded if
they don't have a landscape
support as well.
So I would wherever possible
always design
and code for both.
PAUL: Just one question
on that.
How many people have physical
keyboards, or slide out
keyboards, do you know? or
what kind of percentage?
RICH: Sorry, I don't have
any statistics on that.
I don't know all the
devices that have
the slide out keyboards.
NICK: No, you probably want to
look at adding some analytics
to your applications, try
and get a feel for
that kind of stuff.
PAUL: OK.
Cheers, guys.
Thank you.
RICH: Also, yeah, have people
do use external keyboards.
Bluetooth keyboards
and other things.
Who knows what they're up to.
Best to support both.
[INAUDIBLE].
KENTON: I was just going to say,
I've got two clients now
and they both insist they just
want portrait, they don't care
about landscape.
I know Google TV guy on the
left there obviously would
love some landscape
stuff, but--
RICH: Happen to be porting
iOS apps across to
Android, by any chance?
KENTON: I might just be
doing that, yeah.
How do you convince clients that
it's worth spending money
on doing both?
RICH: Just take a D1 in.
And wait for them to slide the
keyboard out and try and type
that email address
in like this.
NICK: Could ask them if
they hate their users.
RICH: Yeah.
Just tell them default--
MATT: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK: One of the arguments I'd
say is, if you mean to or not,
you're already shipping an app
which runs on landscape
default phones, it runs on
landscape default tablets.
It runs on landscape
default GTVs.
If you're not requesting
touch.
So they're already shipping an
app that does this, they're
just shipping a really, really
poor user experience.
So either you go to loads of
effort to lock it down and
stop it from doing what it
really wants to do and fight
the user, stop them from using
it how they want to use the
app, or you have
happier users.
It's up to them.
RICH: And if they're--
KENTON: It is quite nice and
easy to sort of lock it to one
orientation.
It's a lot less code as well.
Is there any public thing that
we can say, statistically this
is a class of devices you
excluding if you lock it to
these orientations?
Because, you're kind
of preaching to
the converted here.
We've got to convert
our clients, the
ones with the wallet.
NICK: I don't know
any hard numbers.
The only ones I can really
think of is the tablet
activations now.
So the public number is we're
activating 70,000 Android
tablets every day.
So they're already going to
not have a great user
experience with the app.
Most tablets are pretty
landscape friendly.
I don't have stats otherwise
for how many
more classic devices--
RICH: Whilst you're convincing
them, make sure they do a
tablet layout as well.
I know they're often not easy
things to convince a client,
especially if they've just
finished their iOS app.
KENTON: I find the Nexus 7 class
size device, actually--
upscale phone apps look
all right on that.
RICH: Yeah.
NICK: Uh, not really.
RICH: Alright.
KENTON: They're not awful.
Not like they are
on 10 inches.
NICK: In portrait, quite
like a phone device.
In landscape, it is more like
a tablet device, I find.
say you have to make a call,
like [INAUDIBLE] apps don't
work very well in landscape,
generally.
Is app to app, but still.
RICH: OK.
With that, we're going to have
to finish for today.
Before we get actually,
physically
kicked out of this room.
Thank you all for joining
us again.
Some great questions from the
Android developer community.
Giuseppe, we'll try and look
into that question, whatever
it was, by next week.
Please add it to next
week's moderator and
we'll take a look.
Cheers, guys, thank
you all very much.
NICK: Cheers.
MATT: Bye.